[Music]
question.
Hello.
Hello. So happy. Thank you. Um so happy
to see you. My name is Rachel. Um I use
she her pronouns. Um, and I'm so excited
uh to see all of you and those of you
who are joining us online. Um, happy
Easter. Um, welcome to this sacred
celebration. If you're visiting for the
first time, um, we extend a special
welcome to you and invite you to scan
the QR code to fill out a visitor form
so we can say thanks for being here and
answer any questions you might have
about uh, this community. Um, before we
jump in, I have a couple of
announcements. First uh table picnic in
the park is on Saturday, April 26th.
That's a week from today. Um from 11:00
a.m. to 2 pm. Join us for a day of
relaxation and fun in Saxi City Park.
This is a familyfriendly activity. Um
bring a picnic lunch for you and your
family, any games you'd like to play or
share. Um and you can scan the QR code
to RSVP for that. Next is our first
Sunday meal is uh the first week of May.
Uh so May 4th um that day we'll be
trying something new with our worship um
service by gathering in the family life
center which is the building at the back
of the property um for the entire
service. Um so you can sign up to bring
a dish or a dessert um to share that day
um and you can do that through the QR
code. Also there are um little bags of
activities somewhere
over there. Oh there you are. um um that
kiddos can do during the service. And
was there anything else? We do have a
nursery provided for kids four years old
and younger. if your kiddo wants to step
out. Yes.
Um if you are feeling anxious about
being in a church setting or if you're
part of the disability community or
you're just feeling a little fidgety
today, um we have an accessibility
bucket right over there, that black
bucket by the wall. Um that has some
fidgets, coloring pages, noise
cancelling headphones, um anything to
help ease any anxiety you might be
having. Um we just ask that you return
those tools at the end of service.
These candles are a sign of the presence
of Christ among us, fully divine and
fully
human. Christ is risen. We give thanks
for the gift of Easter that runs beyond
our expectations, beyond our categories
of reason, even more beyond the sinking
sense of our own lives. We know about
the powers of death, powers that persist
among us, powers that drive us from you
and from our neighbor and from our best
selves. We know about the powers of fear
and greed and anxiety and brutality and
certitude. Powers before which we are
helpless. And then you, you at dawn,
unquenched, you in the darkness, you on
Saturday, you who breaks the world to
joy.
Yours is the kingdom, not the kingdom of
death. Yours is the power, not the power
of death. Yours is the glory, not the
glory of death.
Yours, you. And we give thanks for the
newness beyond our achieving.
Thanks, Rachel. If you guys would stand
with us, we're going to get started with
our music. And we just invite you guys
to be a part however you're comfortable.
Sing out, um, clap, dance, but be
present. We invite you to just be
present and enjoy the service.
Your voice it
thunders. The oaks start
twisting. The forest sounds with the
cedars
[Music]
breaking. The waters see
you and start their riding
from the depths. The song is rising.
[Music]
And now it's rising from the
ground.
Holy,
holy,
holy, holy Lord.
The earth is yours and
singing.
Holy,
holy,
holy, holy
Lord. The earth is
yours. The earth is yours.
Your voice
throw is
shaking. The mighty mountains are our
tren.
[Music]
Creation sees
you and starts composing.
The fields and trees they start
rejoicing.
[Music]
And
now it's rising from the
ground. And now it's rising from the
ground. Hear us crying
out. Hear us crying out.
Holy,
holy,
holy, holy
Lord. The earth is yours and
singing
holy,
holy, holy Lord.
[Music]
The earth is yours and
singing.
Holy,
holy,
holy, holy
[Music]
Lord. The earth is yours and singing.
Holy,
holy,
holy, holy
Lord. The earth is
yours. The earth is
yours. The earth is yours.
In Ephesians 1, it says, "Because of the
sacrifice of the Messiah, his blood
poured out on the altar of the cross, we
are a free people, free of penalties and
punishments chocked up by all our
misdeeds. And not just barely free
either, abundantly free. He set it all
out before us in Christ. a long range
plan in which everything would be
brought together and summed up in him.
Everything in deepest heavens,
everything on planet Earth. It is in
Christ that we find out who we are and
what we're living for. It's in Christ
that you once you heard the truth and
believed it, found yourself home free.
Make beautiful
things. You make beautiful things out of
the
dust. You make beautiful
things. You make
beautiful things out of us.
[Music]
all this
pain. I wonder if I'll ever find my
way. I wonder if my life could really
change at all.
[Music]
Though this
earth could all that is lost ever be
found. Could a garden come up from this
ground at home?
[Music]
You make beautiful
things. You make beautiful things out of
the dust.
You make beautiful
things. You make beautiful things out of
us.
[Music]
Roll
around. Hope is springing up from this
old ground.
Out of chaos, life is being
found in you.
[Music]
You make beautiful
things. You make beautiful things out of
the dust.
[Music]
You make beautiful
things. You make beautiful things out of
us.
You make beautiful
things. You make beautiful things out of
the
dust. You make beautiful
things. You make beautiful things out of
love.
[Music]
Oh, you make me new. You are
making me
new. You make me new. You are
making me new.
You make me lose. You make
me. You are
making
me. You make me. You
make
me. You
make things out of the dust.
You
make me
feel. You make
me out
[Applause]
[Music]
of oh.
Oh, you make me new. You are
making me
new. You make me new. You are
making me new.
[Music]
The moon and stars they
were
sun. The savior of the world was
[Music]
fall. His body on the cross. His blood
poured out for us. The weight of every
curse
upon
[Music]
me looked
away. The son of God was laid in
darkness. A battle in the grave. A war
on death was waged. The power of hell
forever. The ground began to
shake. Stone was rolled away. His
perfect love could not be overcome.
Now death, where is your sting? Our
resurrected king has rendered you
defeated.
Forever he is glorified.
Forever he is lifted high.
Forever he is with it. He is
alive. He is
[Music]
alive. The ground began to shake. His
stone was rolled away. His perfect love
could not be
overflow. Now death, where is your
sting? Our resurrected king has rendered
you to
me.
Forever he is glorified.
Forever he is
lifted high.
ris. He is
alive. He is alive.
[Music]
We sing
hallelujah. We sing
hallelujah. We sing hallelujah.
is
over. We sing
hallelujah. We sing
hallelu. We sing
hallelujah. The heaven is
over. We sing
hallelujah. We sing
hallelu. We sing
hallelujah. The lamb is over.
We sing
hallelujah. We sing
[Music]
hallelujah. He is
glorified
forever. He is lifted high. Forever.
He is
rising. He is
alive. He is alive. Sing that one more
time.
Forever. He is
glorified.
lied high.
Forever. He is risen.
He is
alive. He is
alive.
Glory
is
your
singing.
Holy, holy,
holy, holy Lord.
The earth is yours and
singing.
Holy,
holy,
holy, holy
Lord. The earth is yours and
singing.
Holy,
holy,
holy, holy Lord.
The earth is yours and
singing
holy,
holy, holy
Lord. The earth is
yours. The earth is
yours. The earth is yours.
God, we believe that you came for the
restoration of all
things. God, you came to make dead
things
alive. You came to redeem the broken, to
restore sight to the
blind, to give life to those who have
felt
dead, to fill up those who are empty
inside.
And God, tonight as we celebrate Easter
together as a community, we remember the
life that was poured out to show us the
way of
love. We celebrate the freedom that we
have because you so loved the
world that you gave your son for
us. And God, we want to live a life
where we lay
down our
rights, our fears, our
brokenness, and we pick up our life in
Christ.
We pick up
peace,
goodness,
faithfulness,
redemption. God, would we follow the way
of
Jesus? Would it transform our
lives? Would we be marked by the joy
that we celebrate at Easter?
that we are free and we are
yours. It's in Jesus name that we pray.
Amen. In the past, um we've wrapped up
this time with a meet and greet before
the message. Um but today we would like
to transition to a tradition that's a
little bit more rooted in um church
history and it's known as the passing of
the peace. Um, and it's where we're
going to impart Christ's peace and
reconciliation to one another. So, if
you would, can you guys turn with me to
our neighbors and just say, "The peace
of Christ be with you.
Well, happy Easter to you all. He has
risen. Some of y'all know. We can try it
one more time. He has risen.
Yeah, y'all y'all know it. That goes way
back in Christian history. So, um well,
it's so good to be with you and uh to
welcome you into this space. My name is
Brett and uh my pronouns are he, him and
um yeah, I just want to welcome you into
to um our Easter service and it's a
special it's a special day and um you
know there's there's folks we have folks
uh traveling in from like out of town
and long distances. I saw James Townsen
is back here and uh he's usually hosts
our online communities but he's made the
trek in and actually his father's here
and uh his his mother couldn't make it
but um his father mother they are
celebrating their 65th wedding
anniversary like this week that
[Applause]
incredible so yeah folks who have
traveled in uh folks who are new uh
thank you for being here I know there's
all sorts of stories and backgrounds and
experiences people have with church and
sometimes it can be a lot uh coming back
into church. In fact, we had um even
folks I think of one gentleman in
particular who um used for like months
he wanted to visit the table but he
would pull into the parking lot and he
just couldn't bring himself to do it and
he would pull out and uh it was because
of church history um and or in his
experience um with churches and um he
was part of the LGBTQ community and it
was just like to be back in church and
it was just like oh my gosh. So um so I
just know it can be a lot. So, thank you
for those who are new. If it's your
first time or just your first time in a
long time, we're really, really glad
that you're here with us. So, the title
uh of my Easter message, oh, before I do
that, also those join us online, you're
not forgotten. I would feel so bad if I
got the end of my message, didn't
mention that. Love y'all lots, too. So,
the title um of our message this this
Sunday or uh well, now Saturday is the
pace of love. The pace of love. And uh
our scripture is uh one of the accounts
of the resurrection from John chapter 20
uh verses
1-16 which reads early on the first day
of the week while it was still dark Mary
Magdalene came to the tomb and saw that
the stone had been removed from the
tomb. So she ran and went to Simon Peter
and the other disciple the one whom
Jesus loved and said to them they have
taken the Lord out of the tomb and we do
not know where they have laid him. Then
Peter and the other disciples set out
and went toward the tomb. The two were
running together, but the other disciple
outran Peter and reached the tomb first.
He bent down to look in and saw the
linen wrappings lying there, but he did
not go in. Then Simon Peter came. If you
know anything about Peter, you know he's
always like the bold one in the Gospels.
Uh following him and he went into the
tomb. He saw the linen wrappings lying
there and the cloth that had been on uh
Jesus' head, not lying with the linen
wrappings, but rolled up in a place by
itself. And the other disciple who
reached the tomb first also went in, and
he saw and believed, for as yet they did
not understand the scripture that he
must rise from the dead. Then the
disciples returned to their homes. But
Mary stood weeping outside the tomb.
As she wept, she bent over to look into
the tomb. And she saw two angels in
white sitting where the body of Jesus
had been lying. One at the head and the
other at the feet. They said to
her,"Woman, why are you weeping?" She
said to them, "They've taken away my
Lord. I do not know where they have laid
him." When she had said this, she turned
around and saw Jesus standing there, but
she did not know that it was Jesus.
Jesus said to
her,"Woman, why are you weeping? Whom
are you looking for?" supposeding him to
be the gardener. She said to him, "Sir,
if you have carried him away, tell me
where you've laid him, and I will take
him away." Jesus said to her, "Mary."
She turned and said to him in Hebrew,
"Raboni," which means
teacher. So, here's the kind of big idea
uh for this Easter message. To
experience resurrection life, that is
really an abundant life in Christ. We
must learn to move at the pace of
love. So what exactly does this mean?
Well, this passage is really interesting
if you pay attention specifically to
what people do and how they do it.
So it it begins by describing how uh
Mary Magdalene, she goes to the tomb of
Christ, but it's it's in the darkness
just before
dawn. And we all know there's a there's
a certain um kind of pace we move in the
mornings, isn't there? Uh some of us are
faster than others. I'm a morning
person, so I'm like kind of up and at
it, you know, like I have about two
minutes of groggginess and then I'm kind
of like on it. In fact, I have a
housemate who uh is not a morning
person, and they recently told me,
they're like, "Brett, I know you're
trying to be just nice, but every
morning when I come downstairs," and
then you're like, "Hey, good morning.
How'd you sleep?" Uh, it makes me so
angry. I was like, I wasn't even saying
like, "Oh, looks like someone's got a
case of the Mondays." Like, "No,
nothing." You know, it was just like,
"Hey, how'd you Oh, there too much." You
know, there's there's a pace. We move in
the mornings, you know, and uh and it
even says, you know, darkness just
before dawn. Like that's like the
darkest part of the night. So there's
even a pace we move, you know, in the
darkness, of course. So, in other words,
you know, I don't see Mary Magdalene in
this moment jumping out of bed,
sprinting to the tomb of Christ. Like,
no, no, no. That's that's not that's not
how mornings go. That's not what we do
in darkness. And right, she's grieving.
We know from the story. So, no one
sprints to a funeral or a graveside. No,
no. So, I just envision her, you know,
really almost reluctantly but sort of
dutifully uh making her way to the tomb
of
Jesus.
And she gets there, she looks in and
realizes the tomb is of course empty.
Now, we've got a shift, right? A
transition. Suddenly her like blood is
pumping. The text says that now she
runs, right? She she runs to go tell the
other disciples, Peter and an unnamed
disciple. And then what do they do? Do
they kind of just saunter on over to the
like No. They're like freaking out,
right? So they they they run. In fact,
we know they're running as fast as they
can because it has that little uh that
little detail about how one pulled ahead
of the other and got there first.
There's sort of speculation that the
unnamed disciple in this is John who
wrote this gospel. So it's possible that
he's kind of like I'm not trying to brag
but one of them beat the other guy, you
know. Uh so that's kind of the image,
right? They're they're sprinting to this
tomb running as fast as they can. And
that's I mean that's quite an image,
isn't it? like this first Easter
morning so quickly transitions
into stress and uh speed and haste and
confusion. And I I think um in so many
ways that kind of that that kind of
vibe, right? This the sort of the
nervous system being on full alert that
that like is sort of a mirror of our
culture, isn't it? Like when I kind of
observe our global society, there is a
franticness in our living. There's a a
certain pace many of us are going that
kind of feels almost unsustainable. We
live in what I would call like a
caffeinated culture, you know, like of
we we love our coffee, but even that
sort of a metaphor for just we love that
kind of bouncy,
energetic kind of quick, you know, kind
of going from thing to thing to thing,
event to event to event. And uh we're
like, we're, you know, we're just kind
of that kind of culture. We're just kind
of going. And I see this all over the
place. Like I can see it in I worked in
the corporate world for many years. And
talk about just stress city. Like I
remember I went through in 2011 I got
laid off and I was part of like these
giant it was wasn't just me. Um it was
you know there was the round of layoffs
I'm trying to say face. I don't know. Um
but uh when I I had all these projects I
felt like they were the most important.
I was stressing out. I was like oh my
god we got to get it was coming up to
Christmas. We had these marketing
campaigns and we're we got to get this
stuff out for these clients. And all of
a
sudden it all just went away and I
realized like I thought all this was
like so important like it's and just
like that me and like half the company
just be like ah it'll be fine. You know
it was almost like there was a almost in
ways an unnecessary kind of stress in
pace to a lot of corporate life right
now. I see it um in the Amazon delivery
drivers. Have you seen this where they
pull up and then what do they do? They
jump out of the truck, they grab that
package, and they literally run. And I'm
just imagining like it's not like
they're doing that three times that day.
We're talking, you know, like 60, 70, 80
stops. I don't know how many. Like
there's a there's a pace to our living.
It's evident in the frazzled faces of
parents trying to spin all of their and
their children's event plates, you know,
things, and just trying to care for
little ones. And it's just like crazy
making. Above all though, I probably see
it most in our collective response to
the question, hey, how you
doing?
Busy. Always busy. And even if we aren't
busy, we feel a little bit bad for not
being busy. So we might still say busy
just to like participate in the
collective hysteria. You
know, you see what happens when you're
in this mode, this kind of bouncy,
excited, rushing from here to there,
from event to event. What what goes on
in your body? Your nervous system, it's
all uh on high alert. You know, you're
upregulated. Your uh your your system,
it's it's dumping cortisol and stress
hormones into your body, right? Getting
you
ready. And in many ways that's just like
those early disciples, right? Running to
the tomb. So we too are sort of running
and fighting and making our way through
life. It's almost like uh we're on the
battlefield of life. You know what I
mean? It's like our life isn't chill.
It's like no, it's like a battlefield.
And to be clear, uh if you get in that
mode, you just may win.
you you might win at success, at uh
moneymaking, at hustle, at
productivity. And to be clear, I do
think there's times, right? There's
moments, of course, when we need to kind
of enter that battlefield. Got to get
some stuff done. You know, that's fine.
The problem becomes when it's chronic.
You know, people talk about, I just
can't turn my brain off. You know, I
just I'm going all day and it's like,
okay, time to take a break. I can't. I
just keep worrying about this and that
and going going
going. The therapist David Kates points
out he says this healing does not happen
on the
battlefield. Love does not happen on the
battlefield.
Connection does not happen on the
battlefield. Now these things only
happen when we slow down. When our
nervous
system
goes In
fact, everyone do that big
inhale and let it
out. Try to do it like make the noise.
It helps like so
inhale. Oh, well that was I already feel
better. And who is it in our story who
slows
down? It's not Peter and the unnamed
disciple, is it? Nope. Mary gives them
the news and they just take off, right?
They they run, they show up, they jump
to a bunch of confused conclusions.
Verse 8 mentions that the unnamed
disciple, possibly John, uh, he
believes, you know, but then verse 9
sort of clarifies, but actually honestly
neither of them really understood what
was going on. They they they did not yet
understand the scriptures, right? So
they they kind of show up, they get all
confused, and they just don't get it. Wh
why is that? I wonder if they're just
too too
frazzled, too much rushing. Like they're
not. They think they're thinking clearly
as we often do. They're
not. And I think you even see this um in
their lack of
emotion as we'll get to. Mary has
emotion, but these two disciple Peter
and the unnamed disciple, there's no
emotion described like no shouts of joy
from the one who believes, you know,
there's there's no stunned sobs of of
grief or happiness or there's nothing.
It's just run around, show up, get
confused. It even says they went home to
their homes like they went
separately.
just that that image of disconnection
and
separateness. They couldn't slow. They
couldn't linger. But you'll notice in
the story, who is it who's different?
Mary, of course, is
different. Like, initially she runs, but
then she
slows. And in her slowing, she begins to
give her body time to feel.
You know, we need to give our bodies
time to
feel. In fact, in the story, it says she
begins to
weep. See, our tendency when faced with
situations of loss or grief or unknowing
is to shift into fix it, fight it, or
flight from it mode. You don't have to
raise your hand, but any fixers with us
tonight? Anyone just got to get this
figured out and then I can rest. You
know, problem is there's always another
problem, you know. Any fighters? Any
anyagram mates? I don't know. Someone
just like I'm up for a fight. You know,
any flight any flight from it? Run away.
Little Monty Python shout out. I don't
know if anyone still gets that, but run
away.
You
see Mary
though, it's different for her, right?
She she slows. She lingers. And I think
this is what our caffeinated culture
just doesn't get, right? We're so good
at the battlefield of life side of
things. And that's wonderful. That's a
part of life. But the problem is it's
not all of life. There's other aspects
to our life. And that's where we begin
to struggle, right? And so we move on,
sweep it under the rug, never talk about
it again. Much much better though. So
much better to slow down, to acknowledge
our unknowing like Mary did. To feel
what we're
feeling. And and I love that Mary does
this, right? She lingers. She stays. She
feels. Mary moves at the pace of love.
And so, of course, it's she who sees the
risen
Christ. It's she who actually lingers.
And I mean, I'm just thinking like, how
disappointed were those two disciples
later? Like, what? I mean, there there
will come a time, of course, when the
other disciples do see Jesus. But
they're not the first. Who was it who's
first? It's Mary. It's the one who
lingered. It's the one who slowed. It's
the one who wept.
Right? This is this is sort of our our
path our actually connection to God in
others is precisely Mary's path. Right?
That that's what we need to do. And how
is it that this all comes about? How is
she the first one? She of course um
looks again into the tomb, right? It's
empty. Uh or sorry, not this time. It's
this time it's the two angels, right?
And she has this conversation with him
like I'm looking for Jesus. She's sort
of getting confused herself. Suddenly
she hears a voice behind her, right? She
turns thinking he's the gardener, has
this little back and forth, and then
what is it that Jesus says that changes
everything for Mary? Do you remember
what he says? Says her name, Mary. It's
like right then she
knows. You see, only when I move at the
pace of love can I discern the voice of
love.
What do I mean the voice of
love? Like obviously in this story uh
the resurrected Christ is literally you
know speaking to Mary, right? And uh and
I think that can and still does even
happen today. I think visions or dreams
or I think of like for example the
mystic Julian of Norwich had these
showings and interactions with Christ
and such. So I think you know that that
can happen. But I want to kind of take
it out of for us the you know the
spectacular the incredible moment like
oh my gosh God's like speaking to me in
this dream or you know I do think that's
more and far between. Um so does that
mean like oh well it's just the lucky
few you know who get to hear the voice
of of love speaking to them? No, I don't
think so. Because you know, if it's true
that all creation is charged with the
grandeur, the the beauty, the glory of
God. Well, then Christ through the
spirit is closer than the air you're
breathing right
now. Right? God is present to you.
Christ is present to you. Which means in
a sense Christ is always whispering
words of love. I I think of it like in
the in the hug of a friend, in the kiss
of a breeze, in the smile of a stranger,
the person who visits and cares for us
when we're sick. The friend who helps
you move. Boy, you know you have a
friend when they help you move.
See, we are surrounded by these whispers
of love all the time. But the trick is,
of course, we don't hear it. We don't
tune into it. And therefore, we don't
end up receiving it. Why? Because only
when I move at the pace of love can I
discern the voice of love. I had a a
moment with my youngest boy, Oak. Uh it
was a week ago and it was one of those
very rare for some of you who know our
living situation. We live with our
brother, sister-in-law, their four kids
and it's us and our three kids, me and
Maggie, my wife. So it's like a lot of
people in the house, you know. So we had
this rare moment where it was just Oak
and I at home. Everyone else was
gone.
And I thought, you know, like my life
often feels a lot of things I'm
preaching on it is kind of like next
thing, next thing, next thing. And I
realized like, you know, as much as I I
do feel like I'm spending time with my
kids in the sense of I'm really doing my
best not to be the, you know, the kind
of loser dad who like doesn't show up to
things, whatever. So, I'm trying to show
up, you know what I mean? Like taking
them to soccer practice, go to the water
polo, go here, go there, you know, all
the I'm trying to do that. But I often
have kind of felt like, am I really like
am I really connecting, you know, like
am I just kind of with them, but am I
really connecting with him? So I asked
him, I said, "Buddy, what is
something like you you like to do that
you want me to do with
you?" And he said, "Uh,
chess and
Fortnite." And I've got to admit, my my
boys, they've been playing Fortnite for,
I don't know, eight, 10 years, whatever,
like a long time. And I've never played
one second of this game. So, we played
chess. Y'all, I I came this close to
losing. I'm not joking. Like, it was
close. Oh my gosh. He's joke is a smart
one. He's so clever. All of a sudden,
this pawn or not pawn, but what the
castle is just coming in from the side.
I'm like, "Oh my gosh, I'm dying." You
know? Um, so we play chess and then we
played Fortnite and it was like this, it
was so fun. I hadn't played a video game
in a long time. and just like have this
moment, you know, of like just just
connecting, just sitting there in a big
empty house, just quietly like playing
chess, just connecting. You know, there
there's something so simple but so
beautiful
about starting to move again at the pace
of love. So, in closing, you know, if
you're looking for some sort of like
tricky takeaway from this sermon, um,
you know, don't don't overthink it. I
hope it's obvious by now. Uh, slow
down, calm
down. Because we often say, I feel so
disconnected. I hear it from people all
the time. I feel so disconnected from
God. I feel so disconnected from my my
partner. I feel so disconnected from my
kids or friends or any sort of broader
community. I just feel so
isolated. Could it be, at least for some
of us, that it's because we're living,
not just occasionally, we're living our
life on the
battlefield? And what we need to do is
slow down, calm down, so that love can
happen, so that healing can happen, so
that connection can happen.
So
church, may you begin to
move not at the pace of
fear, not at the pace of
ambition, but at the pace of love, the
pace of
resurrection, the pace of Christ. In the
name of the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. Amen.
So, if you uh if you attend the table
regularly, then you know that uh we've
been in the season together of Lent. And
uh the season of Lent began 40 days ago
at a a service that's called Ash
Wednesday. And some of you participated
uh in that. And uh at that service, it's
customary at the end that folks come
forward and receive the sign of the
cross in ashes upon their forehead. And
so today to mark the end of the season
of Lent, a time of kind of repentance
and preparation and preparing to walk
with Christ, you know, to the cross. um
to to mark the end of that season and
the beginning of uh this season of the
the season of resurrection. What I want
to do is invite you forward to receive
not the sign of the cross, but instead
uh just a circle of lavender oil upon
your forehead or your hand if you'd
prefer. Um and it will just be a a
symbol of the empty tomb. that that
circle just symbolizing the empty tomb
and kind of a way to receive um
resurrection life today. So, the way
we'll go about this is if you're with us
normally, you know, we celebrate
communion and and we um form a line
right here. So, we'll just do this very
similarly where we'll just go row by row
starting here at the front and we'll
just form a line right here. If you're
kind of out on the wings, it might be
best if you kind of go around and back
through the back and then form the the
line here. So, we'll just start front
row and then as that starts to get
short, then second row and so on and so
forth. Um, right here, uh, I do want to
invite everyone to participate if you
would like to, uh, regardless of your
exact, you know, theology or maybe
you're like, I don't know, I felt really
far from God. I don't know if I believe
the right things or something. You know,
if you would like to participate and
connect with Christ um, in this way,
then you're welcome to do that. Um,
having said that, there's also there's
no pressure. If you're in a place where
you're like, I'd rather not, that's
okay. Perfectly okay, too. So, um, what
I'm going to do, I want to close us with
a prayer and, uh, and then we'll start
this, uh, this ceremony. So, you can bow
your heads or close your eyes with me.
Lord
Jesus, we long for your resurrection
life. We hunger for your presence.
Oh, but we have been undone by worry,
overwhelmed by our stress,
frazzled by our ambition and comparison
and
fear. Lord Jesus, teach us to move with
the unforced rhythms of grace. Teach us
to live at the pace of resurrection
love. In the powerful name of Jesus
Christ, I pray.
Amen.
[Music]
You guys are welcome to stand with us as
we sing this last song. If you would
like to sit in a posture of just um
receiving, that's perfectly fine as
well. But let's close out with this
prayer, this question to God. We ask him
to help us to slow down, to recognize
him, to invite him into these moments of
our busyness and our
[Music]
chaos. Would you teach
me? Would you make me lie
down. Would you build a house by the
waters that refresh?
Will you call my name and lead me
[Music]
alone
and
restless my mind to sleep?
[Music]
Will you call me back and gently slow me
down? Will you show me now? What's a
losing word to
keep? Oh, good
shepherd. Oh, good
friend, slow me
down. Slow me down.
Oh good
shepherd. Oh good
friend, slow me
down. Slow me down.
[Music]
When my tables
bent with only greed and
gold and my grasping hands are afraid
you won't
provide. Will you pour the wine that
loosens up my hope?
Set your table here with what truly
satisfies. Oh good
shepherd. Oh good
friend, slow me
down. Slow me
down. Oh good shepherd.
Oh good
friend, slow me
down. Slow me down.
On the busy streets trying to make
myself a
name. If the work is yours, there's
nothing I can claim.
Will you lead me home to the pastures of
your peace?
[Music]
If the house is yours, I'm sitting at
your
feet. Oh, good
shepherd. Oh, good
friend, slow me
down. Slow me down.
[Music]
Oh good
shepherd. Oh good
friend, slow me
[Music]
down. Slow me
down.
Slow
me down.
[Music]
Is it on? Okay, there we go.
Sorry. Thank you so much for being here.
Again, if you're new, um we'd love for
you to scan the QR code or fill out a
card on your way out just to say thanks
for being here or to answer any
questions you might have. Um we could
all use more relational support and
spiritual connection. The way we do that
here at the table is through meetups. If
you're not yet part of a meetup, uh you
can scan the QR code to find one that
would work for you. Um you can also scan
the QR code to find more info about
upcoming events. There will be no
service tomorrow. um enjoy the day with
your family. Um we'll be back one week
from tomorrow at our usual time on
Sunday, April 27th. Um directly after
service, if um you go out and you're
looking at the hallways, the ones to the
right, the adult classrooms, that's
where um we'll meet for the egg hunt. Um
and then also after everyone is uh
welcome to attend. We're having a meal
um in the building at the back of the
property. Um it's catered, it's free,
and we'd love to see you there. Um, so
now I'm going to send you into your week
with a blessing. You can hold out your
hands in a posture to receive it. Um, or
just open your heart to these
words. You are a child of
God. You are a child of
God. This is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day. So, as you
go into your week ahead with this yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in between, go filled with
the assurance that you are
worthy, you are loved, and you are
accepted just as you are. And go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
into contact with. Be blessed. Have a
happy Easter.
[Music]
Oh my
good. Oh good
friend, slow me
down. Slow me down.
Oh good
shepherd. Oh good
friend, slow me
down. Slow me
down. Slow
me down.